- [Stephen] Happy to be talking to
Professor Matthew Frye
Jacobson about his recent book,
"One Grain of Sand" that was published
by Bloomsbury Academic Press in 2019.
Professor Jacobson, thanks
for being here with us today.
- Thank you for having me.
I'm delighted to be talking with you.
- [Stephen] So it was
exciting to read your book
about Odetta and in particular
her album "One Grain of Sand."
And I'd love to hear you talk first
a little bit about
Odetta's life and career
and about the family
that she was born into.
- Okay, Odetta was born
in depression-era Alabama,
but left for the West Coast
at a fairly young age.
She was four or five when her family left.
And in that sense, she's very much a child
of the great migration,
in that she did get
at least a short experience
of the Jim Crow South.
And in fact, some of her earliest memories
of overt racism were actually on the train
on the way out of Alabama.
But they settled in Los
Angeles where she grew up
very much in a kind of more cosmopolitan
certainly than Alabama, in the sense that
one of her best childhood friends
was a Japanese American girl
who ended up being interned
shortly after Odetta's
family moved to Los Angeles.
So it was a more mixed and
cosmopolitan kind of setting
than the one she had been born into.
But largely an African American culture
and largely transplanted,
and recently transplanted
from the South.
Her mother was what in the
day would have been called
probably a washer woman or
perhaps a cleaning woman,
but she worked for a theater troupe.
And in fact, that ended up
being Odetta's first connection
to the theater.
It was that community
that recognized in Odetta,
as a fairly young girl, the
kind of talent that she had
and that she might be able to hone.
And that community actually pitched in
to sponsor her classical training.
So she was classically trained as a singer
and ultimately a performer.
She goes on to attend
college in the theater arts
and really is studying
to be a classical singer.
People talked about her as
the next Marian Anderson,
which ultimately is something
that she chaffed at.
She says, "I didn't wanna
be the next anything.
I wanted to be me."
And she found her way kind of flukishly
into the folk world in
North Beach and the Bay Area
and decided to throw aside everything
that she had been trained to do
and to pick up folk music,
that was in the early '50s.
She'd been in a theater production.
And probably there's no question,
she had a future in that
if she had chosen to stay with it.
She was in "Finian's Rainbow" in 1949.
That was the direction
she was headed into,
but she really chucked it
aside in the early '50s.
And by 1954, she's
cutting her first album,
which is a folk album.
And I think that is the
thing that drew me to her
as an object of study.
And as, I mean, just someone
who I admire so much.
The beauty of her music
and the power of her voice
and her talent is just, it's majestic.
But I was really interested
in that story of,
how does a young African American woman,
around 20, 21, decide
that she wants to make
this kind of unheard of jump
from the classical world
that she's really been
trained for and reared for,
into the uncertain world of folk music.
And I just think it's a fascinating story
from just the kind of
performance and arts angle,
but the politics of it
are also fascinating.
I mean, she from the
beginning really talked about
the folk repertoire as a
resource for African Americans.
So her first album is 1954.
She's already fairly famous
nationally by 1957, 1958.
This is a period where there
really was no such thing
as African American studies in
the curriculum, at any level.
And she recognized the
repertoire by which I mean,
the field hollers, the
prison songs, the blues,
as a resource for African Americans
to recover their own history
and to know something about,
not only where they had been,
but also to know something
of their resilience
and their inner strength and power.
And that's how she talked
about the repertoire.
And she always talked about
herself as both an archivist
and an educator in that sense.
Other people talked about
her that way too, ultimately.
But that was another piece of it
that was just really fascinating to me.
And that really underscored
what an important figure
she was in her moment.
- [Stephen] Why don't you take
us to "One Grain of Sand."
Tell us a little bit about the album
and why you decided to write
about "One Grain of Sand."
- So this book was written
really on assignment
for a series that's
called "33 and a Third."
And the assignment is to pick
an album and write about it.
I wanted to write about her.
I should say, I mean, this project spun
out of another project.
There was going to be an Odetta chapter
in a much broader book
about the cultural history
of the civil rights era.
So she had been on my mind for some time.
When the opportunity to write
for this series came up,
I listened to all of her
albums and really thought about
where I wanted to enter this conversation.
Musically, there might've been
different choices to make.
I think most people might
have chosen her 1957 album
as the one that's maybe that
was kind of her signature.
But "One Grain of Sand"
is by anybody's measure
one of her best albums and
one of her most important.
And for me as a historian,
the most important thing about it was
that it was released in 1963,
the same year that she appears
on the stage alongside all of
those other luminous figures
in both the arts and politics
at the March on Washington.
But it's also, this was
the occasion of the march,
it was the 100-year anniversary
of the Emancipation Proclamation.
And so as a historian kind
of entering this work,
thinking about it as a
historian's meditation
on an artistic production,
that was really compelling
because her repertoire and
her approach to the repertoire
and the moment of the album's
release gave me permission
to reflect on that 100 years
of African American history
between the Emancipation Proclamation
and the March on Washington.
And in a sense, that's how
I would describe the book.
It's a historian's
meditation on that 100 years
through the lens of Odetta's own artistic
and archival practices.
- [Stephen] And most immediately,
in advance of the release of the album
on January 1st, 1963,
what was Odetta doing?
What was happening in the United States
that perhaps shaped the
production of "One Grain of Sand"
in advance of its release
on January 1st, 1963?
- Well, she had been traveling
through the folk world
almost for 10 years at that point,
just about 10 years at that point.
And had been a fairly
well known national figure
in those circles for the
last five of those years.
This is a moment when to be a folk singer
really was to be something.
There was a whole circuit of
really important folk venues
from the West Coast through
cities like Denver and Chicago,
to the East Coast, especially in New York,
but also Philadelphia and Boston.
And she was really one of
the mainstays on that circuit
in the late '50s.
It was in those years that she was
not only honing her
craft as a folk singer,
but expanding her repertoire.
She spent a good deal of
time actually studying
the old Smithsonian Lomax
recordings in the libraries
of the University of California
when she was still living there.
She spent a lot of time really
as a student of the music
and recognizing the political
import of the movement,
of the music.
She never fancied herself
a terribly important political figure,
even if she totally felt that
there was political import
to what she was trying
to do as a musician.
So when she showed up at
the March on Washington,
for example, it was at the
invitation of other people.
There were other people who
said, you gotta be there.
We have to have you there.
We need Odetta's voice as part of this.
And she always answered that call.
So, that kind of thing had
probably started happening
a few years earlier.
So she was already well known
on the political circuits at that point,
but much more well known
just as a folk singer
who had a really deep and
rich kind of repertoire
that reflected something important
about the African American experience.
- [Stephen] Well, it's a
beautifully structured book.
And you talk about the ways
in which "One Grain of Sand"
embodies Odetta's approach
to the folk repertoire.
It says something about how she worked
with the archive of black history
and was also for her a vehicle
for radical expression,
in your words.
Can you say a little bit more
about how you organized
the book into sections
and how you decided which
songs on "One Grain of Sand"
to look closely at?
- Sure, yeah.
Well, I will say there are
two pieces of it that were
the germs or the kernels
of the whole idea.
One was something I understood very well
and the other was something I
felt I needed to understand,
but didn't quite.
The thing I understood very well
was the significance of that
folk coffee house circuit,
that I just described to you.
As a political and social
space, I just thought that
these venues represented a
really important crossroads
in the culture where all kinds of people
were coming together in an era
when the left really needed that.
I think one of the things
that we often forget
about the modern civil rights era
is that the civil rights
public that had existed
before the war was just
decimated by McCarthyism
and by the kind of postwar,
cold war politics of anti-communism.
And so if there was going to be a revival
of a real robust kind of
civil rights politics,
as we know there was, the first thing
that was gonna have to happen
was a new civil rights public
was gonna have to be
kind of found and forged
and encouraged and nourished.
This is in some ways, it's
a story that's been told
as the transition from the
old left to the new left.
It's a story that's been told
in terms of the transition
from the black church to secular spaces,
like college campuses,
all of that is important.
But I think that these coffee
houses in the late '50s
and early '60s were a place
where old left folk singers
like Pete Seeger and The Weavers
and new left figures like
Joan Baez and Bob Dylan,
old kind of blues figures
and their publics,
like Huddie Ledbetter and
the kind of Alan Lomax crowd,
new folk singers like
Odetta herself, beat poets,
it was just a really protean space
where all kinds of people came together
and you could see at some of these clubs,
like the Gate of Horn in Chicago
or the hungry i in San Francisco.
You might hear Odetta singing
field hollers one night
and then hear a kind of left comedian,
like Mort Sahl the next night
and then hear a blacklisted
folk singer like Will Geer
the night after that.
You just didn't know kind
of what you were gonna see
from night-to-night or week-to-week.
And I think that the publics
that crossed through those spaces
are really important to the
story of the early civil rights,
the postwar iteration of the
civil rights, freedom struggle.
So that was a piece that
I knew I wanted to tell.
And the song that I chose to do that with
was "Cool Water," which
was a kind of folk standard
initially sung as a cowboy song.
Made most famous probably by Roy Rogers,
although he wasn't the first to do it.
But Odetta's version is just,
what she does musically with
it is completely different.
It was to serve a very different purpose.
She sung it in a metaphorical register.
It's quite literally about a cowboy
and his horse dying of
thirst in the desert.
And she turns it into
this kind of metaphorical,
really powerful kind of allegory
about the cool water of
freedom and being denied that.
So I used the occasion of that song
and what she does generically
and artistically with
that song to think about
the political work that was being done
in those coffee house spaces,
by the cultural work that
singers like her were doing.
So that was kind of in place
before I started writing.
That was something I knew I wanted to do.
The piece that I knew
I needed to deal with,
but I didn't know what to do with it,
was the song "Midnight Special,"
which is probably the most
famous song on the album.
It's a song that it's
been done so many times
by so many different people,
it's in some ways the most
familiar of all the songs
that's on that album.
I was always a little bit confused by it.
It's a song, the Midnight
Special is a train,
and the refrain is shine your light me.
And I never could figure out,
the lyrics are clearly,
it's about a prison house,
so there's that dimension.
It's a little bit hard to follow.
And I was never sure whether
shine your light on me meant
that the train was going to
redeem the narrator of the song
and take him or her away,
or whether it was actually a suicide song.
And in researching the song,
which dates back to the late 19th century
and various versions,
what I discovered is that
you can find versions that emphasize one
or the other of those things.
Odetta herself actually
really played with that.
So her versions changed over the time.
So that in the 1957 version that she cut,
it's very clearly the song of redemption.
Whereas in the 1963 version,
that's on "One Grain of Sand"
she's emphasized different things,
she's reordered the verses in such a way
that it's clearly a song
about death on the tracks.
So that was a puzzle that
I was trying to figure out.
Figuring out how to understand the song,
but also placing it in the long kind of,
long live genre of the prison song,
which is so important in the
African American tradition.
And so, again, it was a piece
of a pretty long stretch
of African American history
that could be meditated upon
and told through the
history of the song itself
and its various variations over the years,
including Odetta's own
variations on the theme.
So those were the two
pieces I started with.
And then the two pieces I added,
one is on the spiritual
kind of strain of the music
and the other is on, there
are two Southern songs,
one is about the boll weevil,
and the other is about
the old cotton plantation.
So taking kind of spiritual geographies
and social geographies and
again talking about those themes
through songs on the album.
That became the strategy for the album
was to try to think really
deeply about history,
but to do it through the
kinds of questions and answers
that were at hand in the music itself.
Which is for me, that's one of the things
that was such a delight about
working on this project.
There was a lot of freedom in terms of
what I could do in this assignment,
but that intersection between political
and social history on the one hand
and artistry and cultural production
and genre on the other.
I mean, that's kind of where I
live as a cultural historian.
So it just felt like a
really rich opportunity
and her archive is really
quite extraordinary
for that kind of reflection.
- [Stephen] Let me ask
you a particular question
about her relationship to religion,
which as you said, is a primary focus
of one of your four sections.
So you quote Odetta
registering some distrust
of institutional religion,
or at least the leaders
of institutional churches
in the postwar period.
She would later recall that quote,
"I didn't believe anything
the minister said.
When the music started I trusted that."
Could you talk a little bit more about.
- Yeah, this was not an
easy piece of writing for me
for several reasons.
One, I'm not Christian
and I'm not an African American Christian.
So, there's some sensitivity
about how are you gonna
approach materials like this?
So there's that, but there's also,
I think the historian's tendency
and I think this runs pretty
deep in civil rights history
as a genre, to take too literally
some of the liberationist's
strains of Christian theology
and to kind of map them onto
the politics of the time,
and clearly that was important.
It's important that the black church
was such a crucial site for the struggle
in the 1940s and '50s.
And that's where a figure
like Martin Luther King emerges from.
It's crucial that King
himself is citing chapter
and verse all the time
in his political oratory.
So these things are important,
but I think they're too
easily oversimplified.
This particular chapter was
something that I struggled with
because I think I
oversimplified it myself.
I'd really just tried to read
African American Christianity
as liberation theology.
And to kind of too facilely
read the political symbolism
of the ways that a figure like
Odetta was using the gospels.
And I was fortunate to
be corrected in that
by our colleague, Katie
Lofton in religious studies,
who read an early draft of the chapter
and said, no, no, no, no,
you have to understand
that Christianity is a problem too.
It's not just the answer to the problem,
it's also part of the problem.
And she gave me some reading assignments,
including a fantastic book
by another of our colleagues,
Willie Jennings on racism
and the Christian tradition,
along with many other things.
And it was actually through the rethinking
that Katie Lofton had urged,
that I actually found
some of those quotes,
including the one that you just mentioned,
from Odetta herself,
talking about religion
in a much more problematized
way, and in a richer way.
So one of the things I
tried to do in that chapter
is not just lose the liberationists strand
of Christian theology
and Christian symbology,
but also to try to capture
some of the complexities
and even the paradoxes
that are embedded in it
in the ways that if it is true,
that Christianity was
one of the symbol systems
for imagining liberation
on the part of the slaves.
It was also one of the symbol systems
that allowed for slavery
in the first place.
And so to try to really
think about that paradox
and to think about how
that carries through
over the 100 years leading up
to 1963 when Odetta is singing
and how she's kind of positioning herself
in relation to those paradoxes
and those kinds of contending streams.
- [Stephen] So the book
in part positions Odetta
in dialogue with,
contention with in some ways
Christian theology, Christian
churches, church goers,
all developing at a time
in which the civil rights
movement is changing.
You also think about Odetta,
as you mentioned already,
as a figure shaped by the great migration.
And I'd love to hear you
talk more about that.
You say that at least a
few of her songs, quote,
"Belong to the vast cross genres cannon
of post-migration black narratives,
alongside Jacob Lawrence's
migration series,
Richard Wright's 12 million Black Voices,
Langston Hughes's One-way Ticket,
or Bessie Smith's Gulf Coast Views.
Can you say more about how her work,
produced outside of the
South for the most part,
engaged historical and
contemporary conditions
in that region and
understandings of the South?
- So the two songs that I
really focus on in this context
are Cotton Fields and Boll Weevil,
both of which are about the South.
But the argument I try to make is that
they're very much, they're
performed outside of the South
and they're performed for the most part
for people who have removed
themselves from the South.
But that that dimension
is really important.
So they're a kind of
backward reflection on,
not just a kind of geographical space,
but a kind of historical space as well.
So there's a temporal and
spatial geography to those songs
that I think is really important.
And so it's not as literally
the kind of migration narrative
that so many other writers,
including singers, made famous.
But I think it's in a similar
genre in the sense that
these are songs that could not
have been performed this way,
nor been thought of as
important in this way,
if they weren't on the other side
of the experience of migration.
And if they weren't, in some ways,
a reflection back onto a space
that had been successfully escaped.
I mean that I guess is the
thing that really defines them.
And I think it's very subtle.
One of the things I argue is that,
that if you listen really closely
and especially in Cotton Fields,
I think it's most subtle and
maybe it takes some study
to really hear it, but
there's a kind of agitation
in her version of that song
that really speaks about
the danger and the hazards
and the violence of the South
and what it might mean to escape it
or what it might mean, in the
literal context of lyrics,
to be entrapped within it.
- [Stephen] So you were
just to think about Odetta,
alongside many other cultural figures
in the mid and late 20th century.
And I just wanna throw
out some names that appear
in your book, "One Grain of Sand,"
and just ask you to say something
about one or more of them,
about their relationship
to Odetta and her work.
I'm thinking of people like
Paul Robeson, Josh White,
Woody Guthrie, Pete Seeger, Nina Simone,
Bernice Johnson Reagon, and others.
- The name that jumps
out at me is Robeson,
because I think that his approach to art
was very much the approach
that Odetta herself adopted.
And whether she got it directly from him,
or indirectly through many
of the mutual acquaintances
that they had, I'm not sure.
But, his idea that that
artistic expression
could be political expression
was absolutely important
to how she thought about
her task as a singer.
And also, I mean, the way
that I think as a stylist,
if that's the right word.
Robeson was famous for performing
in this kind of operatic mode
that disrupted the expectations,
especially of white audiences.
But it kind of busted some of the genres
of African American
performance at the time
in a way that I think was really important
and really powerful.
And I think that that is something
that Odetta took as well,
because as careful as
an archivist as she was,
in studying these old
African American standards
in the Smithsonian
collections and the like,
she was never simply trying to reproduce
what she was hearing.
She actually was making the songs her own
in a really important way.
And the way I ended up putting it is that
she inhabits the moral center of a song
more than just reproducing the textures
of the archive as she found it.
And I think that that's a similar way,
although his style was
completely different.
I think that Robeson did
something very similar.
When he sang a song with that
just booming operatic voice,
he was doing something that
the archive was not giving him,
but he was bringing his own
special kind of power to it.
And I think that that's something
that she had in common with him.
- [Stephen] So as an
interpreter of the songs
that you write about, some
of which, many of which
were already in the folk repertoire,
you describe how Odetta also
queered the gendered conventions of music
as it was inherited by her.
Can you talk a little bit
about the ways in which
she queered those conventions?
- Yeah, I think it's an
important part of her work.
I mean, some of the things that she did,
well, by choosing the repertoire itself,
I mean, most of the
songs that she performed
came out of a very male kind of tradition.
And some of the things
that she did with her voice
played with a kind of gender neutrality
or ambiguity that I think
was really important
to the power of the song.
And it was something that a
lot of critics at the time
commented on without knowing
exactly how to understand it.
A lot of white listeners
didn't like it, frankly.
They wanted her to sound more like a lady,
or appear more like a lady.
But I think that her conscious decision
not to be that performer
was part of how she saw
the politics of what she was doing.
I mean, it was about kind of
disrupting the status quo,
disrupting expectation, pushing
people to think in new ways.
And I think that for her gender was
as important a part of
that project as race was.
- [Stephen] Now I wanted to invite you
to talk a little bit more
about Odetta as a performer.
You've written of course, extensively
about this album as a piece,
as an archive in and of itself.
But you also write in the
book about Odetta on stage,
what she did for audiences,
how audiences understood
her in the various settings
in which she performed,
before and after 1963.
So I wonder if you could take us through
some sense of what
audiences would have seen,
what they would have appreciated,
what they would have heard,
had they been in one of
Odetta's performances
around the time in which
"One Grain of Sand" appeared?
- It's important to
remember how young she was.
She was still just in her late 20s.
And so she was still
developing as an artist,
or maybe early thirties by then.
But she was still developing as an artist
and she was changing.
And now with the advantage of retrospect,
you can really see that.
One of the most striking things about her
and this was part of her power
and it was something that
she never stopped using,
was that classical training.
I mean, she held the stage
with the kind of majesty
of the great operatic singers.
She just did.
She held the stage in a way
that she just looked immovable.
She looked as immovable as she sounded.
It was part of the power
of her performance.
In those years, she had
a kind of seriousness
that I think was more
characteristic of her performances
in those years than later on.
She, her friends would say,
was one of the funniest people
you would ever meet in your life.
And there's plenty of evidence for that.
And you can hear that in some
of the later live recordings.
But for the most part in the later ones,
you don't hear that so much in
the late '50s or early '60s.
I think that became more a part
of her kind of stage patter later on.
She had a fearsome sense of humor
and she over time learned
how to deploy that.
But I think that that was
less a part of her act
in the years that we're talking about.
I think the more striking thing,
through probably the late '60s
was just the power of her presence
and her seriousness of purpose.
- [Stephen] So Matt you've
written about Odetta.
You've spoken to many people about Odetta.
You've taught about Odetta.
I know she's made her way into the courses
that you've given over the years.
And my sense is from hearing you talk
that you think of her as a person
who was profoundly influential
in the late 20th century,
but also perhaps a person
who's not widely recognized
by many people today.
So can you talk a little bit more about
how you see the influence of
Odetta on say other musicians?
You mention this in the
book, people like Joan Baez,
Rhiannon Giddens, her influence on
politically-engaged Americans,
people like Rosa Parks,
artists like Spike Lee,
perhaps the ways we understand
African American history today.
Love to hear you talk a
little bit more about her
perhaps unrecognized influence.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
And it's one of the puzzles really
that I never quite resolved is,
why is it that our students
really don't know her?
I mean, she's almost unknown
among younger Americans right now.
Although I think that
that may be changing.
My book, it turns out,
is the first of a flurry
that are gonna be coming
out soon about her.
So maybe that will change.
But it is really fascinating
that after about the '70s,
or maybe the '80s, when she was still,
she was on the college circuit,
she would travel around,
she would play at college campuses,
and she was still well known
among college students,
certainly when I was
in college in the '70s
and probably beyond that.
But then really kind of drops out
as someone who is kind of
famous to a younger generation.
Which is just kind of
odd because she was truly
one of the most famous performers
of her generation at the time.
I mean, at the time that she's standing
next to Martin Luther King in 1963,
everybody knew who she was
and everybody knew why she was there.
So it's kind of startling.
But that ceased to be
the case at some point.
On the other hand, she never stopped being
a musician's musician.
And I think she still is very much that.
So, you mention her name to
someone like Rhiannon Giddens,
and there's an immediate enthusiasm
and excitement to talk about who she was
and her influence and what she did.
I've been privileged to
have this conversation
with several current singers,
like Giddens or Valerie June.
And for them, Odetta never went away.
I mean, she never stopped being important.
It's one of the important
and puzzling perhaps
things about the arc of
her career and her fame.
Bob Dylan famously said, that he picked up
a flat-top Gibson guitar
because of Odetta.
That was the power of her
influence at the time.
And somehow that just faded for listeners.
And I guess folk as a genre
is not nearly as popular now
as it was a generation ago.
But still, people, our students know
who Woody Guthrie was.
But rare is the student
who knows who Odetta was
until I tell them.
- [Stephen] Well, I would
just say the book, you know,
"One Grain of Sand" goes a long way
towards explaining Odetta I
think, for audiences today
and contextualizing her and
using her to help rethink
the ways in which African American history
from roughly 1863 to roughly 1963,
with bleeding on both
sides, was formulated by her
and can be reinterpreted with her in mind,
by historians, artists, and others today.
And I guess I just wanna
ask you by way of closing,
if you have any other
thoughts about the ways
in which you hope that the
book that you've written
will work in the world.
What are some of the things
that you would love readers,
whether they're students, or
fellow academics, or others
to appreciate about
Odetta or to be thinking
as they walk away from this book,
about other projects
that they might take up,
or other ways of understanding the world?
- I really appreciate the question.
Even if I've learned over the years
to try to be very modest
in my ambitions for a book,
'cause when you send
it out into the world,
you just never know what
people are gonna do with it,
or how it will be taken up.
I guess my fondest hopes would be twofold.
One would be that it would urge people
to pick up her records
again and listen to them
and really think about the
brilliance of her artistry
and the power of the political work
that she did through her singing.
I mean, if in some small
way, the book contributed
to a renewed interest in Odetta herself,
that would be probably the most
a person could hope for writing a book.
The other thing I would say though is that
there is something about method
that's embedded in the book
that I hope our students
would pick up as well.
That intersection that I mentioned before,
that zone where social and
political history meet culture,
and the culture industries
and cultural production
and artistry and genre, is
a really, really rich zone.
And I would hope that
book might model something
about cultural analysis
and the ways in which
something as seemingly
self-evident as a song
can actually open up all kinds of doors
for historical inquiry.
So that's maybe the wider
ambition of the book.
But if the book achieves
anything at all, I'll be happy.
- [Stephen] I think it achieves a lot.
Matthew Frye Jacobson
thank you for talking to us
about your most recent
book "One Grain of Sand."
- Thank you so much for the invitation.
This has really been a delight.